se intensifica la represión del gobierno
nicaragüense contra la oposición este
viernes la policía allanó las oficinas
de la prensa un diario abiertamente
crítico con el gobierno de daniel ortega
y el más antiguo del país la policía
acusa a los dirigentes de la publicación
de fraude aduanero y lavado de dinero
pero para los periodistas estas
acusaciones son mentiras inventadas por
el gobierno bueno de todos sabemos que
tengo una medida más del del régimen
contra los contra la prensa
independiente pues que quiere callar no
pues de cualquier forma pero nosotros
seguimos con esa vocación de continuar
informando pese a todo veto la
electricidad fue cortada internet
bloqueado y los servicios informáticos
paralizados es un golpe más para este
periódico después de que se viera
obligado el jueves a suspender su
edición impresa por la escasez de papel
dado que las importaciones de los
insumos para las impresiones están
retenidas por la aduana como lo denuncia
el medio de comunicación a menos de tres
meses de las elecciones en nicaragua el
presidente daniel orte ha sido acusado
de censurar a sus opositores mientras
busca un cuarto mandato consecutivo al
menos 32 opositores han sido detenidos o
puestos bajo arresto domiciliario
incluidos siete precandidatos
presidenciales sólo uno quedan ama ya no
aire se pareció a besar a la prensa que
a
necesitamos otro gobierno y elecciones
no tenemos esperanza porque esto ya está
solo el panamá varias ong registran la
desaparición de al menos 20 medios de
comunicación independientes desde que
ortega asumió el poder en 2007